good seven and a half eight okay
I think I'm I'm a 10 in the middle let's
have you scoot into the tables
depends on the city in L.A the number
goes down
okay in uh
let's say you're in like a
International Hub somewhere oh
International Hub yeah I mean okay okay
um like like La for example
um on a good day a solid like a strong
eight okay
I would call myself a 10 but that's
because I'm no matter who it is like no
one's ever gonna think I'm the prettiest
girl or like there's not ever there's
always going to be somebody that thinks
I'm ugly so I'm just gonna call myself a
10 and be happy with that
I like that you know what I mean not
everybody likes me not everybody has to
okay we'll let everybody answer go ahead
I'd give myself an eight
if I was down south or in the midwest
I'd be Beyonce but here in La you feel
me it really just depends on what part
of well we're in Santa Barbara but I'm
from La I'm from the hood so in the hood
I'm definitely a 10. you feel me but
when you go to Beverly Hills stuff like
that you you fat you got a belly little
fupa then yeah your number go way down
so Beverly Hills versus the hood you
know let me know
[Music]
um I would rate myself like a seven or
an eight
okay I'd probably give myself a 6.5 or a
seven I think it depends on the city and
state too like in Florida it may be like
a seven but here in California I may be
like a 6.5
yeah I think I'm six 6.5 I think that's
about accurate
those are kind of changing my mind I
think he has a lowballing but I was
gonna say like a
seven or eight but I'm gonna go with the
eight
I say five I think I'm an average chick
oh not pretty no what that doesn't mean
I don't think there's anything wrong
with average talking about looks alone
I mean I think like there's nothing
wrong with being average I think if you
take 10 girls at the table like half of
us probably are average yeah I think no
one wants to be like honest with you
just because you're not saying you're a
10 doesn't mean you're not confident
either there's a difference between
realistic and just not confident I agree
completely yeah I just I don't know why
like we live in the society where
average is seen as a bad thing like most
people are average not everyone can be
like if you think about if you're an
eight that means you're in the top 20 of
beauty you should have had top 20 of
beauty results so that means um I don't
know modeling contracts I don't know you
know um eligible top 20 10 men in your
DMs or
um have you seen it not not just like
like Siri taking you seriously but go
ahead there's also been Beauty studies
um they've done where they've like had
eight faces lined up of different like
kinds of beauty Superman model Beauty
with the chiseled features and like you
know what people actually find most
beautiful is most familiar so it's like
more the girl next door look that was
actually rated the most beautiful or
even like somebody like I've noticed
like the more that I've been around
couples
um people tend to date people that we
kind of resemble them or someone that
they love like their mom or something I
don't know why that is again it's
probably the familiarity thing that she
just pointed out but I've I've I've
continued to notice more and more but
since being in La that a lot of people
tend to date people that kind of look a
little bit like them so it doesn't mean
that necessarily like it's the beauty
standard it's just beauty Beauty in each
Beauty I'd like to say that beauty is
not subjective it's objective there's
been many studies like people tend to
find the same things attractive like
people might have like certain types
where it differs a little bit but in
general like it's not subjective it's
yeah and every man woman
until like like three years ago when it
became popular to have big lips and as
someone like yeah and I was bullied for
my big lips growing up until it became
like people were getting lip injections
I'll fix that man I'm not going to
I think of myself on what
what uh
yeah
okay then I okay in my mind my mind in
my mind in my mind in my mind I'm a
millionaire in my mind I'm a millionaire
and a PhD in my mind and I feel like
that so therefore I am
you are absolutely perfect so you're
saying you don't have any acne your hair
is perfect every single day like you're
in the best shape of your life you're
saying you have absolutely nothing that
you think you can improve on yourself
I'm not saying that but I'm saying that
I would consider myself a 10. I don't
know what other people would call me
call me I think maybe you're thinking in
different categories because objectively
the golden ratio is a measure a measure
of facial facial Symmetry and it is
objective you can look at someone's face
and see how closely they match and so I
think when a lot of people say what
they're talking about is this is how I
measure up to this ideal standard of
beauty though I do think yeah you're
right over time or whoever said that
over time Society does value different
aspects of women's Beauty as time
changes
women make 70 to 80 of consumer buying
decisions so all the media is marketed
towards women it's not for men what men
what men likes really has not changed
natural I told you see but I said
earlier like it really does depend on
the country and it does depend on where
you're living because it's a lot
different in America than it is in
Israel I lived in Israel for over four
years and the beauty standards there
wildly completely different than yeah
when I got back here when I got back
here I went and I wanted a nose job
right away as soon as I got back I went
and got Botox I went and got lip filler
I didn't feel beautiful here by beauty
standards at all but when I lived in
Israel I was very confident and I felt
great because there they don't care
about those beauty standards right they
don't care about it
no they've done studies on this like
with men all over the world I mean I
lived there first time I've lived okay
I've lived in Germany I've lived all
over the world too so we could go back
and forth than the I lived game but in
general men tend to find the same things
attractive I don't believe that's true
at all but okay well but what do you
think might find attractive
um I mean fit feminine friendly in
general
um symmetrical face I mean I think you
kind of know it when you see it if we're
being honest so supposedly like um you
know biologically like where the men are
attracted by a woman that looks like
she's capable of being a child so like
yeah to me that's the only way that we
can say what we know men like they're
all different between what men like
yeah it's not sometimes one thing like
oh if you have a small nose Every Minute
Men in general aren't that picky and
also I don't like supermodels some men
like the BBL big booty Latinas like
everyone has a different type so you
can't just put men into like a certain
category I mean men really aren't that
picky they swipe right on dating apps
like 50 of the time like yeah men just
really are they're not picky on who they
[__] but they're picking on who they
want yeah
and another thing is
be the complete you can be the complete
and total package and get delivered to
the wrong house
so then you pick the wrong house
no I'm saying no I'm saying you can walk
into a room and be attend to somebody in
that room but go up to the wrong guy
okay let's let's do it let's do a
different examples is lizzo going to be
a 10 anywhere no because she goes to
Japan that's exactly what I'm that's
exactly what I'm saying no no but she's
not going to be a 10 anywhere I mean we
could argue that maybe like you know
well yeah somewhere like I said in the
house
just like every woman they have they
could be the exact perfect package for
the perfect person right but that's
exactly what I'm trying to say lizzo if
you want to use her as an example she's
a beautiful person on earth right right
I think what she's getting at every
single person on Earth I mean I have
common sense where you get in
I think that's where you get it wrong
we have to generalize in order to have
conversations sometimes we no we have to
otherwise if we're gonna have a
conversation about every single
exception but we're gonna be here all
day
I have a question I have a question if I
said you guys look like lizzo would you
take it as a compliment
I think what Pearl was trying to get at
is that it's okay to be normal it's okay
not to be a 10 out of 10 in society's
standards everybody is told nowadays
that they're special and that you're
attend yours and no let's be for real we
have to be honest with ourselves we go
out into the world I'm gonna go out
somewhere somebody doesn't like black
girls guess what I'm gonna have to do
except that people don't like black
girls I'm gonna go out there and change
the world's opinion but that doesn't
make that doesn't change how you feel
about yourself yeah but I mean what I
feel about myself because I'm going off
the society
I feel that way but she's saying she
goes acid rate our looks not ourselves
there's a big difference
come on even if
no I mean it is when you're saying
you're a 10. if you're including persons
I think that we're having a little bit
of confusion about objectively there is
an objective Beauty standard you can
look at a woman and there are different
across races across ethnicities across
all different types of things there are
women who are objectively beautiful when
they walk in a room you know that's a
10. you know it you know it when you see
it but there is relative Beauty like
like
are saying it depends on where you are
and you may have somebody who for that
for that culture for that area that's a
10 and it looks different than the
objective 10 that all most people if you
have a room full of a thousand people
from all over the world they know when
somebody walks in that's a 10
objectively because you can see it's the
facial symmetry it's just the math and
our brain comprehend it as Beauty 100
and if you bring somebody with blue eyes
somewhere where there's predominantly
not blue eyes they're immediately going
to get like a double look or be held to
like oh wow that's beautiful because
it's not seen as often or whatever the
case may be I'm not just I'm just saying
blue eyes because I that's what I have
so I'm not gonna critique somebody
else's look but yeah what I don't
understand is who is the shot caller
that said oh this is the perfect
structured face this is what beauty is
and you know another thing is ridiculous
to me is that okay this is what a 30
year old should look like this is what
you should look like when you're 20.
this is what yeah
how tall are you five seven okay would
you date a guy that's five foot
I have really oh plenty of times five
foot seven inches man I [__] a little
four
yeah no it look where I come from look
you you just blessed and at my age you
just blessed to give somebody that you
feel me wants to show you some love
honey and show you a good time honey so
you got to go along with it baby if it's
if it's yo you feel me your type then
it's your type height shouldn't matter
you know what I mean yeah I don't I
think that's shallow to be honest to put
somebody down just based off their women
women do though if you look at the
filters on dating apps like the most
common filter is six foot and up and
most women have that filter on if they
can I have a question I feel like most
men like shorter women as well they do
yeah five two is like this they want a
little tiny one yeah they're bad short
guys
no problems
so for those of you who are working in
the adult industry I'm curious what you
think your life will look like about 10
to 15 years in the future like what do
you picture where do you picture your
careers going I mean I've definitely
been thinking about that a lot since I
got pregnant and also before as well
um
that's also why I kind of stepped out of
the
corn industry itself because I was
realizing that you know at least with
only fans yes they can screenshot yes
they can screen record everything and it
can be put out on Reddit or whatever
but that I'm on the Hub
anyone can look me up and now it kind of
sucks like looking back on it I don't
regret my decisions because they got me
to where I am today and the person that
I am today and I will always be thankful
for that
um but I do wish I went ahead and did my
research before and did things a lot
differently than I did
um
but I wonder did you know before you
started so this is something so I'm a
career coach and I help people find jobs
without buying college degrees so I help
people get into Tech and different
Industries Blue Collar doesn't really
matter whatever people want to do I'll
help them figure out how to do it and so
I'm curious about if if it's common
knowledge that if you do that kind of
work later on down the line it may show
up and the employer may choose not to
hire you and they're legally allowed to
do so and how how have you like planned
for that on down the line I went in I
went ahead Kiana still is my real name
but I changed the spelling of it I use a
fake glass legally you changed it no oh
okay okay so if I walk into a job they
you can't correlate Kiana kumani with my
real name
um what if they start like making
technology to like find your face
I mean if they already have them they
already have but honestly after the work
that I've done I don't see myself going
back to nine to five
um I do want to go to college and I do
want to get my Nursing degree because I
do want to go and be a traveling nurse
and help out in different countries and
I don't think it really matters when
you're going to be a nurse
if you've done corn I don't know you see
that as an issue because I'm I want to
help a lot of employers a lot of
employers do and it will impact your
prospects and if that if that is the
case then that is the case but right now
I'm trying to stack my money as much as
possible and again invest in Airbnb
property yeah yeah and do as much as
possible I don't want to waste my money
on stupid stuff yeah I think it's dumb
that a lot of women in the industry get
into the industry and they are so they
have never had that much money before so
they go and buy designer purses designer
shoes
yeah they waste all their money they
spend it and they don't learn how to do
their tax forms they don't learn how
they don't learn how to write off things
that they're paying for on a daily basis
to keep up with their own their own like
look like when you're when you're an of
model I can write off these nails every
time I get them done
everything else your own taxes or do you
have CPAs I do my own I've I've because
I did my business agree I actually like
took courses and [__] like that and I
actually really really enjoy doing that
I want to help more people do that when
it comes to of
um but no I definitely have a plan for
after I'm done with the industry that
I'm in right now did you start an only
fans because you couldn't get a job with
your degree as many as many know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible